what was your favorite Justin Bieber
joke that you got to do
there's no it's it's a there's a
thousand great jokes in that show but I
think my favorite was I said um I said
Justin a lot of people have been
pointing their fingers at you lately and
those are just lesbians telling a barber
how to cut their hair he was a good
sport was he would seem like a good
sport on the special he seemed like
you'd be a good sport well I mean he was
21 that week we had earlier it would
have been abuse I called him the king
joffrey of Pop how did you did you get
to talk to him much after the roast like
I'm imagining after the roast you guys
have a party do you know get to kind of
talk it down usually it's interesting we
threw him Comedy Central threw him this
huge after-party and he he blew it off
really he's got a plane he went to Vegas
he just screw it I'm gonna go party but
you know what he's a rock star he's 21
years old what would you have done at
that age I'm just be happy to be out of
the house I was happy to hang out and
hit on Martha Stewart at the after-party
now was so you hung out I heard that you
after party you hung out with Martha
Stewart and Snoop Dogg was there as well
that's right oh yeah anything you want
to tell us I mean that's a funny I'm
just picturing Martha Stewart Snoop Dogg
in you that it sounds like a good time
ironically she's the one who's been to
prison
[Applause]
and you know we get nervous these roasts
are high-pressure so snoop a lot of
times during the commercial breaks will
give me the old elbow and we'll go in
the back you know and maybe you know
decompress a little bit sure and Snoop
pulled out is whatever you would smoke
stuff out of and me him and Martha
Stewart got a little stoned
yeah but she didn't want to smoke
directly so I shotgun to one right a
normal we only had one left
she was great sport I had been busting a
lot of your fans room set you don't have
a Grammy but Martha Stewart's here she
can be your Grammy
[Laughter]